what's going on guys Greg outta here
John Humphrey here Tony Gilroy my
brother Jeb eke away or those other
channel Jeb too long time ago he shot a
short film that I again participated in
I'm in here for like a minute or
something finally put the damn thing
together
Dragonball J spoof odds on me
bye jabby coho and will Jon
[Music]
pretty girl
money
[Music]
I remember hiking that
oh yeah no you're going Maggie I won't
let you have a hibachi I say you're
going down like a McCoy
oh they come take it from me so itself
[Music]
Lauren gosh
movie movie
[Music]
[Music]
kill horrify my last text message
give it up
[Music]
whoa I wasn't there to see this one of
your balls
[Music]
just happened
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well you can be customers as backup -
can you turn to Dragonball J after these
messages
what you mean I walk look brother you
suggest - I'm just a you think I'm obese
or is it Nepal oops if a guy like me
gonna get cocky
okay how are they artists even
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one dragon ball chains and you just a
would come eventually brother
as if I you cannot defeat the oughta go
against too much power so I practiced
train study under the guidance of
Hopkins your recent gain and power does
not frighten me it's do it with this
power I could destroy even aku but the
sheet rock do not hit brother I will
destroy the possible their powers do not
match mine custom I'm far more colorful
and you realize I've only shown you a
text of what I can do the techniques I
wound up going to be power over death
itself impossible oh my Bellingham wha
greater than yours yes you have the
power we can you not have it still leave
it can I walk away from this one huh the
different defeated a good why my not
have well I'll tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lookit there something ometer tight
budget the top I got a bigger dick they
have fun she says what we was bringing a
barber closet your power cannot max why
I am far more powerful than you realize
I know
[Music]
there you go
I was incredible down the can get her
ready yeah it's so good
a little done I was well assembled man
don't leave a the crashes on me I did
everything on that my dear my idea I
added it wrote it choreographic actually
fun fact I was supposed to choreograph
it I was choreographing it and I greatly
delayed on that to the point where it
annoyed my brother he does seems like it
worked out really well nevertheless when
I was coming up with it you know I loved
it she reacted this is tyrone i they do
Tyrone Magnus would totally dig this
I should have tied around my brother's
Star Wars short he really liked that a
lot
but I know Tyrone the Dragon Ball baby
yeah I've just got to this point in the
video comments a Thai runs channel tell
them to check out this video because I
think you would really enjoy it honestly
bother him incessant incessantly like
how did you guys do with me when you
want me to watch something go and tell
Tyrone a little think about it it seems
like they're all like alright great
you're gonna have to wear some type of
cryofreeze like wear a headband this
bandage my carrying right now but I'll
put it all I care about no good yeah man
he said it turned out really well
actually I remember shooting it was a
hike up that now it was a [ __ ] yeah I
believes they ran up it and you read
there that I didn't think I was like oh
wow even tired
pain in the ass is freezing I thought
the editing was really well done the
bites are not really good extra bad
animation oh that was so funny yeah
trippy is far guys I was going to be a
little quick thing yeah I actually
turned out to look like a fulcrum
they're doing so much at it so quickly
it's like it's a cartoon out there
rather like this throw the voice a out
really quick and just being like this is
oh yeah like how I felt when I was like
damn this might actually is an actual
cartoon I wasn't sure what I was taking
like a while for him to do this I mean
he's running his own channel and between
having to edit this whole thing yeah
after seeing him like how do you see
where things are yeah yeah this looks
like it took you a long time shows up on
the screen there yeah this is a lot of
fun man I did wait we should do a short
film with my brother we should when did
you make this over a year ago I don't I
don't remember this at all yeah before
away over years before I met Lauren gone
oh wow yeah okay doesn't reply to my
last text message she's out sailing with
her boyfriend so if you take one thing
away from this video it's the Lauren God
really needs to get better at
communication that's kind of what this
story is all an allegory for yeah am I
to watch the ship but they're also I
don't remember everyone's name - who
were there who be who they raid 3 raid 3
that large whatever might I did on this
channel that's right yeah that was true
she's one of the fighters there yeah
that's where I met her was on the side
of this just so glad it's finally on all
my hard work it was the hardest thing
memorizing those lines yeah man I was
way too high all the time back then yeah
I could not remember a damn thing and
then you you still showed up you brought
the smolder you know you're formidable
enemy and you guys destroy the moon
together we get you know I you guys
showed up you're like you're like Iceman
and pyro yeah and then I like pink I
like that when he goes staying or super
saiyan or whatever he does like that his
hair just get
yeah that like that whole like Raj shut
up being all like big and spiky is a
good spoof of Dragon Ball yeah so play
just like the scenes that you have the
hair in front of his face and it's just
like you just kept talking it just like
this hilarious just to have that angle
just work the pilot that you wanted he
wants love well you just like having to
keep that straight face it just seems so
funny
you got that library up file never out
got me the mo where you can't even see
his yeah I was a great show yeah those
yeah this this is really well at it it
to comic-con you'd and it's just
something I'm not applying that way he
was fighting all five of them and I was
yeah I wasn't good backing up hitting
every like old-school Jackie Chan stop
dividing me around sometimes when you
see a group fight you do sit there going
why are they all taking turns like this
is like that one scene shot sequence
with all fighting at one time was crazy
your brothers free visit so even my team
I hate him watching that outtakes was
just great because it felt like when you
watch all the use like oh man owes
well-put-together
then you forget that there's tons of
scenes where they have to do over and
over yeah just because every single spot
doesn't look fluid so that's a shot with
a real production crew and stuff like
this was crazy nothing like we've ever
four people in a dream yeah more people
tone mandatory yeah if you do this and
this and this privatization oh yeah that
raise the rate three short we did with
you me and hoody yeah us through yeah
what can we help them we make this work
these guys subscribe to the javi tube
challenge a peak away town with the
Jabby Tube channels where he has content
like this apparently subscribe to the
real rejects if you want to it's really
your choice John Humphrey yeah the MVP
of the movie fights and screen junkies
mow down go check it out
Tony Gill has a plot it's in the gamer
and you could follow us at our
patriarchy go over there patriarchy calm
slash the real rejects have a good time